تم إعادة تصور macbook pro الجديد
بكل طريقة
، فلنبدأ مع مستخدمي لوحة المفاتيح
الذين يقدرون صف وظيفة الارتفاع الكامل
على لوحة المفاتيح السحرية المستقلة
وقد أحضرناها إلى macbook
pro حيث تحل المفاتيح الفعلية محل شريط اللمس
مما يعيد الشعور المألوف باللمس
من المفاتيح الميكانيكية التي يحبها المستخدمون المحترفون
، تم وضع لوحة المفاتيح
باللون الأسود المطلي بأكسيد مزدوج بشكل جيد والذي يسلط الضوء بأناقة على
الحروف الرسومية ذات الإضاءة الخلفية على المفاتيح
ويكملها
لوحة التتبع القوية التي تعمل باللمس والرائدة في الصناعة
والمثالية للتطبيقات الاحترافية
على جانب واحد ، يوجد منفذ HDMI
للتوصيل المريح
بالشاشات وأجهزة التلفاز ، منفذ Thunderbolt 4 الذي يتصل
بأجهزة طرفية عالية السرعة وفتحة بطاقة sd
تتيح الوصول السريع إلى الوسائط على
الجانب الآخر ، يتمتع مقبس سماعة الرأس
الآن بدعم متقدم لسماعات الرأس عالية المقاومة
وهناك نوعان آخران من
Thunderbolt 4  ما مجموعه ثلاثة منافذ
في
النظام ونعم
magsafe يعود إلى macbook
pro
magsafe 3 لديه d جديد  esign الذي يدعم
مزيدًا من الطاقة في النظام ، ولا
يزال بإمكانك الشحن عبر منافذ Thunderbolt ،
كما قمنا أيضًا بتوسيع الشاشة لأعلى
وحول الكاميرا ، مما يجعل الحد العلوي
أرق بنسبة 60 في المائة مما يمنحك المزيد من
مساحة الشاشة
ويستفيد نظام التشغيل mac OS بشكل كامل من هذه الميزة
الإضافية  مساحة عن طريق رفع شريط القائمة
لأعلى وبعيدًا عن الطريق ،
ولفه تلقائيًا حول الكاميرا
لمنحك مساحة أكبر للمحتوى الخاص بك
عندما تقارن طراز 14 بوصة
بجهاز Macbook Pro السابق ذي 13 بوصة ،
ستحصل على قفزة عملاقة  أداء
يصل إلى سبع ساعات إضافية من عمر البطارية ،
وشاشة أكبر مع XTR وكاميرا متطورة
وصوت عالي الدقة والمزيد من
المنافذ كلها مقابل 19.99
، وعند مقارنة الإصدار الجديد مقاس 16 بوصة
بالطراز السابق ، ستحصل أيضًا على
تعزيز هائل في الأداء
والقدرات  مقابل 24.99